[Music]
[Music]
the 2019 remake of The Lion King has got
us so excited but how it'd be different
from the original 1984 Animated Feature
there are plenty of fascinating
differences that only true fans will
notice so keep watching to the end to
discover the most exciting addition of
all photo realism it seems too obvious
to say the main difference between the
remake and the original is that one
looks realistic while the others in
animation but there's more to it than
that it's actually CGI
rather than real-life animals however
director Jon Favreau explained that they
wanted the remake to have a sense of
realism by borrowing techniques from Sir
David Attenborough's nature
documentaries you only have to glance at
scar Rafiki and Zazu to realize how
different the animals look in the 2019
version the hyenas the hyenas are a
major example of this focus on photo
realism the director told Empire that
the hyenas had to change a lot because
it didn't feel like they matched up well
with the photo realism Favreau explained
that a lot of the stuff around them was
very stylized in the original and
there's another difference when it comes
to hyenas originally they were called
Shenzi Banzai and edy but in the remake
they're called Shenzi as easy in Kumari
what's even more exciting is that Disney
is introducing a brand new character
into the Lion King franchise but more on
that at the end of this video
voices it's not just character names
that are different it's also the actors
voicing them no more will be Goldberger
Shenzi the new all-star cast includes
Donald Glover as Simba Beyonce as Nala
Seth Rogen as Pumbaa she would tell a
Gaea for a scar and John Cooney is
Rafiki
Favreau dish that it was wonderful to
find actors that could remind the
audience of the original performances
but also bring something new and fresh
and current however there's one iconic
voice that's the same James Earl Jones
is reprising his role as Mufasa Favreau
explained it was a way of carrying the
legacy across and keeping a connection
- the original however even that voice
is slightly different the direct
revealed the timbre of the actor's voice
had changed that served the role well
because he now sounds like a king who's
ruled for a long time no son you stay
with the other Cubs facial expressions
although we gain a lot from the remakes
photorealism we also lose some of the
nuances of the original like the facial
expressions animation supervisor Andrew
R Jones explained they had to elevate
the animal status slightly without
breaking their physicality by giving
them obviously human life gestures he
added that they did some tests and when
they pushed it too far it felt like a
cartoon they look like puppets rather
than living things compared Simba's
facial expressions when scar tells him
to leave and you'll notice the
difference it's also obvious during the
Stampede scene Hakuna Matata
it's not only the facial expressions
that have changed its the way the
animals move - this is most notable in
the Hakuna Matata montage where Simba
Timon and Pumbaa walk across a waterfall
while on the log
zoom in on Timon and you'll notice a
major difference in the remake he's
walking on four legs in the original
animation he walks on two legs teenage
Simba also looks much less stylized in
the remake he doesn't have those Tufts
of hair on his head and chest camera
angles do you want to see even more
side-by-sides that show the differences
between the two films when you study the
trailers for the remake you only realize
the subtle differences in camera angles
when you look real close
zoom in on Simba placing his tiny paw
and his father's big paw prints at first
glance it seems like the remake is
totally copying the original but it's
actually a different angle which is
again all about the photo realism of how
a lion would actually move new music
fans the original movie will be relieved
that their favorite tunes are back the
audience can still sing along - I just
can't wait to be king and can you feel
the love tonight of course they'll be
performed by different voice actors but
there's even more of a difference than
that there's also a brand new song by
Sir Elton John called never too late the
movie makers have kept the continuity by
using the same music legend to create
the new tune they also worked with Hans
Zimmer again who has rejiggered his
original score' humour we can expect
some new jokes too excuse me let me see
what we're dealing with that vowel
revealed that although audiences will
still
feel a connection to the animated film
they've actually taken a lot of
liberties with it and that includes the
humor he worked with his team to
understand the way memory works and what
expectations fans of the original will
have and then they were able to analyze
the animated feature and notice where
they can increase the humor they also
looked at which jokes didn't hold up as
well in this current era length Favreau
has been keen to point out that his
movie is not a shot-for-shot remake he
said that it diverges quite a bit and is
much longer than the original film why
did he need the extra time the director
explained that they've given it more
dimension not just visually but both
story wise and emotionally it's 30
minutes longer in fact the new movie has
a running time of just shy of two hours
new character our final difference
between the two movies is perhaps the
most exciting we get a brand new
character it's an elephant true voiced
by comedian Amy Sedaris these fast tiny
creatures earn their name thanks to
their long noses resembling elephant
trunks Sedaris has worked with Favreau
before on the 2014 food truck drama chef
do you think the remake will live up to
the original or not let us know in the
comments make sure to subscribe to the
things for more videos like this one and
be sure to give this video a big thumbs
up thanks for watching
[Music]